on Mother's Day Ivanka Trump took the
opportunity to tweet about the so-called
wage gap between men and women but
instead of recognizing that it doesn't
actually exist she blamed it on
pregnancy and having children which
actually is true but doesn't speak to
innate sexism in the free market
it speaks instead to the fact that those
who spend less time in the workplace
earned less money she tweeted out a
piece in The New York Times that
admitted as much quote today on Mother's
Day we must confront that motherhood is
now a greater determinant to pay
inequality than gender the New York
Times piece acknowledges quote when men
and women finish school and start
working they're paid pretty much equally
but a gender pay gap soon appears and it
grows significantly over the next few
decades so what changes the answer can
be found by looking at when the pay gap
widens most sharply it's the late 20s to
mid 30s according to two new studies in
other words when many women have
children unmarried women without
children continue to earn closer to what
men do naturally the time suggests that
public policy must be changed in order
to force men to work less or push
employers to cut back hours or use the
government to push paid maternity leave
which is exactly what about control has
been doing regularly and which President
Trump suggested on Mother's Day to
Trump's Mother's Day message stated
quote I am committed to working with
Congress to help mothers and fathers
have paid family leave so the childcare
is accessible and affordable and to
invest in the comprehensive care that
women receive the community health
centers through these reforms and my
2018 presidential budget we will enable
access to the critical health care
services women need here's the silliest
part of all of this if the real gap
appears with marriage and children why
would we penalize single women in the
marketplace by equalizing all pay
regardless of female choice and why
would we penalize the men in marriages
who are helping to support their wives
and kids by cutting their pay simply to
satisfy the feelings of women who may
end up with the same household pay with
or without regulation imagine for a
second a husband or and 60 grand a year
and his wife you turn 50 grand but now
after the first kid she works part-time
and makes 30 grand a year
would really benefit the family to push
policies that would result in the
husband being paid 45 grand and the
white forty five grand just as you can
spend more time at work the legislation
makes leftist feel good and among
because a leftist it's sort of
disquieting that she had so much power
over daddy I'm the bench of hero show
well this is ben shapiro and i'm ben
shapiro you know the deal
alright so starting off the week on an
auspicious no but before we get started
with president Trump's weekend
activities and all the fun that is to be
had there and Democrats going completely
over the top which they are doing they
can't stop themselves in the media
declaring a class one natural disaster
we've must first say thank you to our
sponsors over at texture calm so as I've
said before I'm an information junkie
and as an information junkie I really
appreciate texture calm texture calm is
about staying more informed for one low
price you end up with subscriptions to
texture come to over 200 plus magazine
full of in-depth interviews and stories
there's a huge list of these magazines
that I've got right here before me we're
talking about everything from National
Geographic and Sports Illustrated to
Entertainment Weekly Vanity Fair Rolling
Stone and Cosmo it's all the major
magazines that you could want in one low
subscription fee right now texture is
offering my listeners a 14-day free
trial when you go to texture comm slash
Ben that's 14 days to try texture for
free when you go to texture comm slash
then normally it's $9.99 a month but
again if you sign up right now then you
get a 14-day free trial you can try it
out my wife reads Reader's Digest on
texture comm we actually had a guest on
the program because I use texture comrad
readers I just saw an article that I
thought was great we had somebody on the
program because of it it's fantastic
again it's a digital app that allows you
to download all of these issues to your
smartphone or to your to your iPad and
then you can read all these as back
issues as well texture calm / been
14-day free trial if you're into
information the way I'm the media that
it's the texture app texture calm / been
for that 14-day free trial
okay so President Trump had himself a
busy little weekend president Trump
needs to stop having himself busy little
weekends and the reason I say this is
because if you actually want president
Trump to succeed at this point
regardless of how anyone voted in the
last election cycle he's the President
of the United States I would like to see
him do good things when he did good
things I celebrated those good things
when he nominated Neel Gorsuch to the
Supreme Court I put on a magnet for
goodness sake but it is important that
he actually be good at his job and
Coulter who has been as big a trump
booster as it is possible to be I mean
she wrote a book called in Trump we
trust not in god we trust in
we trust she actually wrote that book
and Coulter today came out and said that
this presidency thus far is a disaster
area and it's hard to argue with that
after the last week because here we're
going to get don't worry we'll get to
the democratic overreaching because they
are and how Trump can fix all of this
which he can and we'll get to how
Republicans ought to treat Trump and all
of that but it is important to note if
you want Trump to do better you need to
treat Trump the same way that you treat
everyone else in your life he needs to
be told he is not doing a good job so
that he can improve if you keep telling
him he's doing a wonderful job when he
is not doing a wonderful job he will
keep not doing a wonderful job in
thinking he's doing a fantastic
fantastic job right now he's blaming
everyone around him apparently except
for himself all of the problems on his
table are self-inflicted
they are self-inflicted you know ever
he's worried about leaks inside his
administration you know one way to end
leaks inside your administration run it
like a decently run business
okay Georgia Shelby Bush should not have
these kinds of leaks but Barack Obama
did not have these kinds of leaks and
that's because they were well-liked in
their own White House they didn't treat
their employees as those are disposable
assets and beyond that actually staffed
up their administration like today the
Congressional Budget Office tweeted out
something about the special invest about
the about the Independent Counsel Act
about reinvigorating the Independent
Counsel Act that's the Congressional
Budget Office why would they do that
they're doing that because somebody
who's an Obama holdover is trolling you
know why they're a bunch of Obama
holdovers because Trump hasn't fired all
the Obama holdovers he hasn't filled any
of these positions well more than three
months into this administration and
President Trump has not actually filled
something like 90% of the vacant
positions that have been created you
basically have it a lot of these
departments the head of the department a
deputy and no one else okay and that
means that the people who are from the
Obama administration are still there
doing what they're doing
Trump has to do the normal things that
our president is able to do Jodl over
makeup made a very good point about this
there's this excuse making that happens
on the right now well he won maybe you
just don't understand his genius
okay winning an election is not the same
thing as being a good president we
should have learned that from Barack
Obama who was a fantastic campaigner and
a really crappy president but Trump's a
whole different story he's not even
doing like the normal things that a
president should do and doing them well
he's not even staffing up these are
basic basic things and it doesn't help
when you go on Twitter and mind vomit
every every couple of days or so so
Friday morning we've spent the entire
week the entire week talking about this
comb
firing and as I said last week he's
number one within his rights to fire Co
me number two should have fired call me
number three fired co me in the
stupidest possible way
ready fired combing without any sort of
warning he did it without any sort of
transition in place he did it apparently
expecting that there wasn't going to be
any blowback and then there is blowback
and he expects the right to be able to
defend him and so we say okay well you
know what he is within his rights to do
that you know he's not doing it over
Russia and then he goes on national TV
and links the Comey firing to the Russia
investigation like a doofus okay it's so
stupid he doesn't have to do this and
then he gets up on Friday and he says
you know what things aren't going well
I'm gonna tweet a bunch of random stupid
crap so here we go here is random stupid
crap number one he tweets this on Friday
morning at 5:26 a.m. so clearly the man
is not sleeping he tweets James Comey
better hope that there are no tapes
unquote tapes of our conversations
before he starts leaking to the press
why why God why why just what why why
would you do this
what would possess you to do this like
do you want to be good at being the
president or would you like to replicate
what happened with Richard Nixon or a
member of Richard Nixon's staff
testified in front of Congress there
were tapes in the Oval Office
Congress subpoenaed the tapes Nixon
refused the subpoena special prosecutor
subpoenaed the tapes he fired the
special prosecutor the Attorney General
designed the Deputy Attorney General
resigned and Nixon ends up being
impeached does this sound or resigning
to this sound like a good like is this
what you want to do you really want
about talk about tapes last time we
talked about tapes we're talking about
Nixon is this like the smart way to do
this first of all do I think there are
actually tapes of the conversations no I
think the Trump says stupid crap like
this all the time just to intimidate
people and it would be nice honestly I
want to be one of the people we just
says about a Twitter feed let's ignore
it right as you can order okay fine I
wrote an entire piece about at National
Review about why we should just ignore
his Twitter feed because it really isn't
all that important right because who
cares okay so you tweet some stupid
stuff sometimes except that then from
selectively insists that we all actually
pay attention to his Twitter feed if you
don't pay attention to his wiretapping
tweet from back in from back in February
then he gets mad at you and then he says
well why don't you paying attention I'm
going to fight in fact he used that as
an excuse to fire Comey he's having a
fire call me because Comey isn't paying
attention to my wiretapping tweet so am
I supposed to pay attention or am I not
now I keep hearing him
seriously but not literally but then
every time I think and seriously but not
literally he's he gets angry and wants
me to take him literally okay that
wasn't the only stupid thing he tweeted
he also decided to be smart to tweet
about press briefing so he's angry at
his own press shop why is he angry at
his press shop because he gives them no
learning whatsoever and Kris tire Walton
Zeynep Rana dinner parada was the press
secretary for Bush she says there is no
communications team on earth that can
handle what Trump has been doing Trump
is just going out there and doing stuff
and I'm like 20 minutes later he expects
the communications team to have some
sort of grand plan on how to handle that
and then when they don't he gets mad at
them it is not their fault that he's not
allowing them to do their job so he goes
out there announces the coaming firing
with less than an hour notice to his
communications team they go out there
and they craft this entirely implausible
thing about how is the Deputy Attorney
General who had recommended the firing
and Trump was just following that
recommendation and then Trump of course
goes on national TV and blows it up and
then the secretary the press Secretary's
go out there and they have to explain
all this and there's no way for them to
explain it so you got Sean Spicer
literally hiding in the bushes at the
White House like between the bushes and
insisting that they turn off the cameras
and turn off the lights so there's not
tape of him talking a insanity so what
if he tweet he tweets he's mad at his
own press people he tweets as a very
active president with lots of things
happening it is not possible for my
surrogates to stand at podium with
perfect perfect accuracy
really so they lying are they not giving
us full information and this idea that
he's SuperDuper active he has passed
legislation last less legislation than
any president in the first hundred days
in modern history he is not that active
he's active on Twitter he's golfing a
lot I'm not seeing tons of things
getting done he's got some executive
orders that are pretty narrow in scope
again I want good things good things
okay many tweets maybe the best thing to
do would be to cancel all future press
briefings and hand out written responses
for the sake of accuracy first of all I
just want to know someone needs to teach
the man how to use scare quotes you
don't need to care quotes around tapes
you don't need scare quotes on press
briefings but that's nitpicking
he says handout written responses for
the sake of accuracy this would be
called propaganda the purpose of having
a press briefing is so people can ask
questions about your policies why is it
that every president who does this has
press briefings okay even Barack Obama
considered apparently ending press
briefings in 2013 and I'm old enough to
remember when Republicans thought that
was a bad thing now Trump says this and
now we're going to get a week of
questions about whether
she wants to quash press freedoms and
then he tweets about the witch-hunt of
the Russia investigations he goes on
national TV with westerholt which we
talked about last week he and he says
that he wants the Russia investigation
to go forward in the most honest and
decent possible manner and then he
tweets out when James clapper himself
and virtually everyone else with
knowledge of the witch-hunt
says there is no collusion when does it
end that doesn't sound like someone who
wants to pursue the investigation very
hard does it it sounds like someone who
wants to end the investigation so do I
actually think that he's firing people
to cover up the investigation no as I
said last week this is my working theory
from day one it has been true then it is
true now it is all true okay my working
invest in my working theory from the
very first day is the reason that Trump
fired Comey is because he got mad and he
acted like a toddler and he wanted him
gone okay like there are a lot of great
reasons to get rid of Comey they were
all true back in January you should have
fired him back then he should have fired
him two months ago he should've fired
him three months ago he fired him in the
middle of this thing and then what
really happened is that Comey was on TV
and he won't go on TV and say the Trump
is innocent and so Trump fired him
that's basically what happened here and
then he made up a bunch of excuses as to
why that is true again none of this is
good for him okay I can't blame the
Democrats when you are shooting yourself
in the face with a shotgun
they take that he's negotiating with
himself like the like the guy from
blazing Sally's got the gun to his own
head and saying if you don't you know if
you don't stop me I'm gonna shoot like
no the Democrats want you to do this
okay this is he's doing what Democrats
want him to do and I know people want to
tune in and they want to hear me defend
Trump I can't defend Trump unlucky
provides me a line of defense that is
credible and decent it is his job to
provide a line of defense that actually
makes sense this is just you don't have
it I'm seeing comments now maybe you
should run for president because you
know what a president should do no I'm
not saying I know everything the
president should do but I can certainly
tell you what a president should not do
okay like this stuff the president
should not do it's just not smart it's
just not smart and again I think that um
who was it it was um Roberts proneural
over at National Review yet a great
piece on this and what he said was
basically my theory is correct that
Trump just egotistically fired Comey
because you didn't like him and it has
nothing to with him trying to cover it
up the problem is the way that he did it
makes it look just like a cover-up which
is really really dumb it's really really
really dumb so Trump's response to all
of this is of course to say that it's
there are a lot of people who are being
critical of him and he hasn't done
anything wrong nothing is easier than
being a critic so here is from talking
about how how easy it is to be a critic
nothing is easier or more pathetic than
being a critic because they're people
that can't get the job done
but the future belongs to the dreamers
okay so he's angry with all the critics
and this is always the easy out is to go
after the critics and will go after the
critics in just a second because I think
it's important to point out when people
are exaggerating the case but I also
think that it's important to be honest
about what Trump is doing right now and
why it is insufficient if he wants to
get the job of government done I would
like to see an actual Obamacare appeal
not the fake Obamacare appeal like an
actual one I would like to see tax
reform I would like to see all sorts of
good things from this president but he
can't do it if he's too busy trying to
extricate his foot from a bear trap that
he set and then jump down with both feet
don't do that
just don't do it I'm going to explain
the second why Democrats are
overreaching and why that actually
provides an opportunity for Trump to get
out of this in a second because this
isn't the hardest thing to actually get
out of Trump's created this because he
has character flaws that are deep and
abiding they haven't changed since last
year him become a perfect human being
just because he won't a victory but the
Democrats have no capacity to simply be
critical instead they have to go way
over the top and so we'll talk about
that in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our advertisers over
at Zeile so Miz fantastic service is
massage on demand so my wife has been
having some trouble with her neck and so
we went to zo comm and we ordered a
massage you can get it on demand at your
place any time that you want it's all
licensed massage therapist she'll calm
you use promo code Ben you get $25 off
your first massage and 20% off all
massages plus a free massage table and
sheet set if you sign up for the sealed
massage membership it's fantastic we've
used it for my mother-in-law we've used
it for my father we used it for a mother
abuse it for my sister my whole family
has used the Oh like I'm I've used it
myself
and the masseuse is that they bring our
top notch again that they are all
licensed masseuses and the ndh I mean
they're really thorough I mean the way
that they work is they actually you
shoot them a picture of your ID so they
can check to make sure you're not a
creeper before they send the masseuse
which makes perfect
but then they send somebody who's really
top-notch they bring the the massage
materials they bring the table they
bring the music the whole thing right to
your house I've said many times on this
show that feeling rich is not
necessarily about being rich it's about
being able to do things that rich people
can do and zeal calm makes it possible
for you to feel rich even if you're not
because the prices on these things are
really not expensive they're very
inexpensive actually and it's top-notch
just as good as you can get at any spot
plus you don't have to wait for an
appointment at the spa they come to you
and you name the time it's really cool
again our listeners get twenty five
dollars off their first massage if they
use the promo code been at checkout and
it gets better you get that zeal massage
membership and 20% off all your massages
plus a free massage table and sheet set
which is a $380 value yours free when
you sign up for that massage membership
there's no initiation for you to join
the membership just great additional
savings on top of the $25 discounts
zeals EEE Elcom and you can go to iPhone
or Android download the app and add that
promo club make sure you use the promo
codes you get the discounts get use that
promo code bed and obviously we thank
them for their sponsorship okay so the
Democrats are overreaching and this
provides Trump with an opportunity so I
just described all the way in which
Trump decided to light himself on fire
the Democrats have decided that they too
will light themselves on fire basically
this is turned into the scene from
Zoolander in which everyone is having a
gasoline fight and then someone lights a
cigarette right that's basically what
this is turned into the Democrats have
decided to combat Trump's silliness not
by standing back and just letting it
happen not by just letting the the
explosion happen then building a
beautiful statue of the of the models
the male models sending each elf on
shooting gasoline at each other instead
they've decided they want to participate
in the gasoline fight so Martha Senator
Mark Warner from Virginia from West
Virginia he comes out and he says that
this is all about the cover-up right
it's all about covering up for James
Comey now before I get to Mark orange
one point one thing out even the
Republicans weren't willing to put
anyone on TV to defend what Trump did
last week there are very few Republicans
on the sunday shows talking about this
even the ones who were like Lindsey
Graham are not friends of President
Trump in fact Lindsey Graham's first
line he was on anything his ABC his
first line was I can't believe I agreed
to come on this week that's not a good
sign
okay but the Democrats were all too
eager to run to a camera which is really
stupid what the Democrats
do is they should pipe down the
Democrats should sit there and they
should just say I don't know what Trump
is doing but it looks kind of suspicious
don't you think
and just underplay it understatement
it's a grand thing in politics but
nobody is capable of it because we now
live in hysteria lend so here's Senator
Mark Warner from West Virginia talking
about how this is really just an
attempted to quash Comey talking but
again the president in this
administration has said there's no there
there
continues through their actions to
indicate that they are afraid of where
this investigation they had let's again
step back for a brief moment this week
we saw Yates testify that the acting at
VA general in general who was fired that
the administration did not appropriate
react to her concerns about general
Flynn
we saw the director of the FBI fired
literally two days before he was
supposed to testify before my committee
we then had the president changing his
reasoning for why he fired him from
saying this was a recommendation of the
acting Attorney General or Deputy
Attorney General to the fact that he was
going to fire in any way because of
Chloe's investigation into Russia
and then we say conspiracy Comey was
about to testify and now he's not going
to accept that commis going to testify
in fact Holman was invited to testify on
Tuesday he said he didn't want to be
invited him to testify in closed session
bad news for Trump he wants to testify
publicly in an open session of course he
does because one thing Trump is right
about is Comey is a showboat he's a
grifter he does love the cameras I mean
the dude is like that he gets up in the
middle of the night he opens his fridge
the light goes on he starts talking it's
like Oh me love the cameras he loves
being in front of the cameras and so
it's not good news for Trump but the
Democrats are saying this is to silence
Comey this was to avoid the Russia
investigation if that was the case this
is the worst conspiracy ever
it's our horrible conspiracies terrible
at conspiracy now here's the thing
that's totally plausible so two things
are plausible one that it's not a
conspiracy because no one could be this
stupid as to run a conspiracy this way
and to maybe someone is this stupid to
run a conspiracy this way they're both
totally plausible or at least partially
possible but my take is that even Trump
and as as kooky as Trump has been over
the last couple of weeks even Trump is
not really trying to do this again he's
not shutting down the the he's not
shutting this down
honestly the best way for Trump to stop
all of this talk is by making someone
the head of the FBI that everyone trusts
right I mean somebody who may be a
Democrat right somebody like a Merrick
garland and Obama appointee to the
Supreme Court it wasn't actually given a
vote Mitch McConnell was saying he
should make merit darlin the head of
that maybe you leave Andrew McCabe
Andrew McCabe is a Democrat you leave
someone there who Democrats really can't
lied about and Democrats are really over
stuffing there's some Democrats have
been saying over the past little while
that they're not going to even approve
an FBI director until a special
investigator is given powers until a
special prosecutor is appointed
that's idiocy that that seems to me a
wild overreach I mean what if what if
Trump appoints like Barack Obama the the
head of the FBI are they going to try
and stop a rock Obama from being here
the head of the FBI because they want a
special prosecutor who the head of the
FBI is going to determine where this
goes from here you know with that said
Democrats continue to overreach and over
here's Chuck Schumer saying that he now
doesn't just want Trump investigated he
wants Jeff Sessions the Attorney General
investigated because Jeff Sessions had
recused himself from Trump Russia and
then recommended that Comey be fired I
have asked the inspector general and the
requests I've made is not only to look
into any interference to thwart the
investigation but whether attorney
general sessions should have
participated in the firing of Comey and
should participate in FBI director you
know attorney general sessions has a
much higher obligation he didn't tell
the truth about meeting with the
Russians so he recused himself now he
seems to be violating that recusal that
would seem on its face to be part of
this and look I called for him to step
down when he didn't tell the truth about
the Russians because it's the highest
law enforcement officer in the land if
the actions of the last week make all
the more reason that he should not be as
Democrats obviously they didn't call for
Loretta Lynch to resign after she got on
a plane with Bill Clinton in the middle
of an investigation of Hillary Clinton
they never called on Eric Holder resign
after he was held in contempt of
Congress is that all of this is a wild
overreach and if from solves the problem
by appointing someone good at the head
of the FBI Democrats can still look
stupid because they're actually out on a
limb here and from connection we saw
that branch off behind them and then all
these people contain Magnum AG Amanda 3d
underwater chess and all the rest of it
and they will actually be sort of right
he'll have accidental
Trump can do that it can still do that
so whose FBI director
that is an awful lot here well we're
going to talk a little bit more about
this we want to talk about the
Republican response and what Republicans
should do and media and basically we're
going to cover this from every angle
because that's what we do here but for
that are going to have to go to daily
wired.com and subscribe $8 a month gets
you a subscription to daily wire.com if
you get an annual subscription then you
also get to be part of the not only part
of the mailbag but you also get a free
copy of Jeremy borings the arroyo it's a
fictional film set on the southern
border action western set on the
southern border in which drug cartels
are attempting to use the ranchers land
as a thoroughfare for drugs and human
trafficking good movie daily wired.com
if you want the subscription or if you
just want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud make sure that you
subscribe and definitely leave a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]